per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi do io sono pari j
oggi siamo su just dance raga mi avete
chiesto di fare una canzone
me l'ha chiesto un po di gente di farla
ma forse tutti perché non so che cosa ci
avete con questa ma devo farla perché mi
avete chiesto tutti la canzone in
questione è questo genere che va bene ok
ragazzi allora la cosa può risultare
molto strada io ci provo
non so che cosa può uscire fuori ma ci
provo a bene dire iniziare dai cos'è
allora ga tutti mi piace far cambiar
stai libro non lo so come viene non ho
idea spero e la particole di merda
troppo tardi
[Musica]
la casa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
a me
massimiliani poggio donne solo
art
non è che fumare quando serve che lo
faremo se in coppia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì
[Musica]
il bagaglio
sambucci vuota gli hanno già curinga c'è
un rischio già grazie sto morendo
questo è pesantissima
[Musica]
io ho voglia
in futuro giuro che sto morendo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
basta basta
raga mi sono ucciso è stata la cosa
impressionante non lo farò mai più
grande style vi giuro
vasto complesso che mi sembra più
tranquilla ragazza young caccia enpa
vigenti
ce la possiamo fare ok cosa dopo chi
sono io delle due gli occhi sono quella
pignocca ovviamente se non solo questi
[Musica]
noi ed è morto nyman e zaia perché c'è
molto della stagione dai
[Musica]
ragazzi è tutto facendo non lo so sto
facendo ma ma la secca tavola fino ad
ora ci sono delle due ma il ragazzo
questo partendo magari in questo modo di
più
[Musica]
dov'è che il male ed è morto per noi la
vittoria
[Musica]
reagan papa
poetica ma il frizzi v8 e canzone
[Musica]
no io no
raga io non so che cos'è sta roba non lo
so non lo vuoi le vittorie non lo vorrei
neanche sapere ma mi sa che ormai ci
tocca a scoprirlo va beh cos'è non
voglio spaventarmi solo questo gesto
[Musica]
alla fine anno cantine gennaio al pit
lane che l'hanno dato guarda ha fatto la
della pena volano vissuto
[Musica]
basta basta la faccio più basta stai
ferma ok rai che hanno una vetrina di
quanto sia stanco più giù
non ce la fai no è finita è finita
beh è venuta grazie a dio ho preso una
stella per pietà regal basta vi giuro
sono morto la chiudo qui perché
veramente non so se se riesco ad
arrivare al letto anche se cielo dietro
penso che non ci arrivano comunque bene
comunque ragazze video è piaciuto
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
attuate la descrizione sky non sia da
quelli scritti iscrivetevi lui ci
vediamo il prossimo video per ragazzi